bisher hielten sich die pläne für die
raumstation die um den mond kreisen
sollen noch im wagen aber jetzt scheinen
sich die pläne zu konkretisieren igor
komarow chef der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos verkündete
jetzt die einigung mit der nasa zum bau
der raumstation deep space gateway in
einer umlaufbahn um den mond alle infos
jetzigen klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
sie wird deutlich kleiner als die ss die
internationale raumstation aber sie hat
ein viel größeres ziel ihr name sagt
schon aus wohin die reise gehen soll im
wahrsten sinne des wortes deep space
gateway was so viel wie tor in den
weltraum heißt und es sind ambitionierte
ehrgeizige pläne für diese station zum
ersten mal sollen hier techniken
getestet und vorbereitet werden die
weltraum missionen in die tiefen des
alls ermöglichen das erste ziel auf das
sich hier vorbereitet wird wäre die mars
mission in der umlaufbahn des mondes
könnte all das getestet werden was bei
einer mars-mission nötig wäre
nur dass die rückkehr vom mond zur erde
in wenigen tagen möglich wäre und sogar
mit einem erheblich beschädigten
raumschiff wie sie apollo 13 mission
gezeigt hat damals war zwei tage nach
dem start zum mond eine sau ein
sauerstofftank explodiert die
mondmissionen musste abgebrochen werden
die astronauten legten die havarierte
kapsel odyssee still und wechselten in
die mondlandefähre die nicht beschädigt
war von dort aus steuerten sie das
raumschiff dass sie mit einem swing by
manöver um den mond wieder auf kurs zu
er gebrachten kurz vor erreichen der
erde nahmen sie die odyssee mit den
verbliebenen sauerstoff und
energiereserven wieder in betrieb
koppelten die mondlandefähre ab und
landeten mit den letzten
sauerstoffreserven auf der erde
bei einer havarie auf dem weg zum mars
wäre das nicht möglich gewesen mit deep
space gateway wird der mond jetzt zum
testgebiet für die nächste generation
der raumflüge schon jetzt wird die
rakete für die erste mission gebaut die
space launch system rakete kurz sls und
die orion raumkapsel erste systeme für
die mission werden an bord der iss
getestet 2024 spätestens 2026 soll es
dann losgehen
die deep space cakes raumstation
soll aus drei modulen bestehen dass
energie und antriebsmodul ein wohn modul
und ein logistik modul in dem auch
experimente durchgeführt werden können
bei bedarf sollen weitere logistik
module angedockt werden
hier sollen astronauten aus verlauten
dann neue technologien in verschiedenen
umlaufbahn um den mond testen denn die
station ist dazu in der lage in
unterschiedlichen höhen um den mond zu
preisen von gas aus können dann
missionen zum mond gestartet werden und
so landet technologien und weiteres
getestet werden der mond wird so zu
einem riesigen experimentierfeld für
lande tests und weitere tests rund um
missionen zu fremden planeten
nach dem durchhänger über den wir erst
letztlich hier berichtet haben scheinen
jetzt noch endlich erste konkrete
schritte zur nächsten raumstation
unternommen zu werden hierzu ist geplant
weitere partner wie zum beispiel die
europäische weltraumagentur esa mit ins
boot zu holen dafür wird überlegt
bestimmte elemente jetzt zumindest für
die menschheit dem weltraum weit zu
normen zitat unser beitrag an der bau
von ein bis drei modulen sowie die
entwicklung einheitlicher standards für
andock mechanismen für raumschiffe sein
zitat ende das meint igor komarow die
nasa hat sie bis jetzt noch nicht so
konkret geäußert aber es scheint nur
noch logisch nach dem ende der iss die
spätestens 2028 kontrolliert ins meer
stürzen muss weil dann niemand mehr für
die sicherheit an bord garantieren kann
das ist übrigens auch ein ziel der
raumstation um den mond die raumstation
soll deutlich länger für mehrere
jahrzehnte oder vielleicht auch für
immer im weltraum bleiben
zum einen können sie die lebensdauer der
module erhöht werden und es könnte ein
system der erneuerung entwickelt werden
durch das alte module regelmäßig durch
neue module ausgetauscht werden und auch
die kosten werden gegenüber der ist es
deutlich niedriger sein nicht nur die
erheblich geringere größe macht die
raumstation deutlich preiswerter deep
space gateway soll nicht mehr dauerhaft
mit astronauten und astronautinnen
gesetzt sein
dadurch sind viel weniger
versorgungsflüge nötig und der energie
und sauerstoffverbrauch ist auch viel
geringer es geht also los mit den
missionen in die tiefen des alls wenn es
neues zu vermelden gibt dann erfahrt ihr
es natürlich hier wenn ihr kein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
unvergesslich den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit 1000 raketen zum
mars da geht es darum wie ihren maske
den mars besiedeln will spannendes video
und natürlich also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran